I love the movies that I've been a part
of someone asked me the other day if I
have any regrets of the choices that
I've made and I'm like regrets and being
able to make movies what the hell kind
of question is that
[Music]
October sky it's sort of a crazy thing
to be that age to be 16 years old and be
starring in a movie audition for it and
I worked so hard to get the role so it
meant so much to me you know I mean I
remember havin go through like auditions
and auditions and auditions and
auditions and then proving myself of
their meetings and all this stuff and it
was like a it meant a lot to me and so
that was very similar to me in the same
way that the love that homer that
character has for rockets and trying to
get out and that kind of drive and love
and ambition and trying to prove oneself
you know to make something bigger than
where you come from all of those themes
are very similar to me in my life at the
time and the real Homer was just such a
lovely guy the book he wrote was
beautiful and he really took me under
his wing he was just so kind and engaged
in me and I remember I worked very hard
I remember that but I loved it so much
and it's such a beautiful story I think
it holds up to this day you know and
then you're working with Laura Dern and
you work with Chris Cooper
and you know I've always loved watching
other actors work I mesmerised on the
opposite side watching them sometimes I
can't always even engage because I just
love watching them and to be that age
and to see great acting that's how you
begin to learn a specific scene we were
in a fight at fight scene with with
Chris Cooper's me and he plays my dad
and I remember being very excited for
the fight scene because I get an actor
you know pretty good young actor I get
to yell and scream and Lamba I remember
coming up to me after about the second
take and him saying to me you're not
listening to me listen to what I'm
saying to you and I remember it went
from me just sort of raising my voice
and yelling and not coming from a real
place to having his words that he was
saying to me hit me like hit me in the
heart
maybe I can go to college maybe even get
a job at Cape Canaveral there's nothing
here for me the town is dying the miners
die and everybody knows it here but you
you want to get out of here so bad then
go don't ya go yeah go go go and I'll be
gone forever I won't even look back to
actually listen as an as an actor as a
person everything becomes different
everything becomes much more significant
and I just remember that him stopping
just saying listen to me and the entire
scene changed and a lot of the next
couple it takes we used were right after
he told me that Joe Johnston who
director October sky directs the first
Captain America he really gave me my
first shot and I owe him a lot that he
believed in me I wouldn't be here here
talking to you I wouldn't have made able
to make all the movies I've made or even
make this spider-man movie without Joe
believing in me I mean I like to think
someone else may have but most likely
not
spider-man farmer bones I mean walking
into the MCU and Marvel Universe it's
huge there's sort of a lot that's
expected of you in the process of making
movies and also as the character and
it's the same kind of feeling of someone
giving you that suit and putting it on
your being like boo is right for me I
mean it's fun I mean it's fun knowing
everything that happens I mean I knew
the events of endgame you know before
endgame came out I love this speculation
because a lot of times you'll read
something or someone will say something
to you and you'll realize oh oh yeah
that might be true you know and it was
someone sort of random idea I
I also think a lot of them are wrong and
that's fun else and it feels like a
pressure it feels like a pressure you
when you're making it you know I think
people love that character and it's so
different from the character of the
comics and you know when you're doing
something as different from the comics
as we did in this I think you kind of go
like I was working with
uh disastrous times he's got a bland
personality
I just basically just very boring no it
was like it was Jen it was genuinely
lovely he puts everything into making
spider-man great he knows how much
pressure there is on him and he knows
how much people care about that
character and he puts everything
physically emotionally mentally into it
I think it wasn't until the literally a
day ago when he saw the movie finally
that he said he could relax he offered
me a lot of advice that I needed and he
just cons me was like yes that's exactly
how everyone feels when they first start
off in this space and we just became
friends that way you know I think he
admires me I admire him both for very
different reasons and as much as actors
in press junkets after the fact like to
talk about how wonderful the other one
was to work with and who knows if it's
true or not half the time I really I
really like him a lot as a human being
and I enjoy being with him outside of
all this stuff so that all went into the
movie as well
donnie darko
I found Donnie Darko and the character
of Donnie Darko very comforting at a
time in my life where I was really lost
and trying to figure out a lot of things
for myself about myself my place in the
world which is what he was going through
my dad says this thing where he's like
the job of art is to disturb the
comfortable and to comfort the disturbed
and like I think that that's very true
in a lot of ways and at the time I think
I was like the world was just crazy you
know you get thrust out into it and
you're like whoa it's trippy you know
and to know there was a character that
was like feeling those same feelings
gave me a real outlet and made me not go
mad myself Donnie you're such a dick
I've always looked up to my sister in a
lot of ways I probably credit her with
the reason why I wanted to act why I
started to act I got into it we were
both starting out Bullough very you know
obviously very ambitious people like
there's a lot as similarities between
the two of them fighting at the dinner
table maybe you should be the one in
therapy then mom and dad can pay someone
$200 an hour to listen to all your
thoughts so we don't have to do okay you
want to tell mom and dad Way stop taking
your medication I have admired her since
I was born now as we do our older
siblings even when we despise them we
love them deeply you know that's the
sibling relationship for anyone who has
one working with her was complicated for
both of us it's weird to put a real
relationship in a fictional space but I
think as actors as like angley said once
I heard him say we pretend to get closer
to the truth and both of us are real
like truth seekers and scenes you know
that's what we love to do and so to be
working with someone who's like calls
you out you know was that why'd you do
that that's weird weird choice
oh that feels true that's honest you
know that it's so present was amazing
when I look back on it now and that's
what I desire I mean that's what I I
think a scene really only is fulfilling
when you're learning something about
yourself in it
you put on a lot of
guys's and disguises but truthfully
where I want to go is places where I
don't have that but I try all these
tricks before something real happens you
know and that is what I love about it
it's like what about this know what
about that know what about that know
what about that what about that just you
know calm down and listen like back to
Chris Cooper every time my sister is one
of those actors too I mean it's why
she's extraordinary because she's
similar to Chris and all the great
actors that I've had the opportunity to
work with they're constantly like just
be still listen be honest as best as you
can if you're an actor it was a long
journey and continues to be a very long
journey for that movie I do know that
passion of the christ' was released by
the same company and they had just made
a extraordinary amount of money from
that movie and from the funds of that
movie they were able to take a risk and
say okay we'll do a theatrical release
because you know we have some despair
and thank God they did I mean it just
goes to show those things you think are
sort of gonna fail or if people are
telling you they are you know life of
something can be so many they're gonna
be so many different lives it's not like
one big opening weekend because it like
be open and didn't no one really saw it
right and actually if he got found again
in London I remember I was making I was
doing a play on the West End and people
start to just generate this energy I was
like whoa what's happening and then it
just came back alive again and has
continued to be alive for or a decade
now
stronger
I just loved the story I love the script
and I love the story and I love the
character of Jeff Bowman I think I said
often about him that he is really a
superhero you know the things that he
went through to get to where he is to
survive and to live today are like of
endgame proportions internally his story
taught me more about my career and about
life than anything I've ever done and
when I read that I just I just really
wanted to be a part of it you know there
was a scene where I'm like dragged
myself across the parking lot and get to
a window and I'm I'm banging on the
window and David Gordon Green let the
camera roll for you know roll out really
and in digital world you can even roll
for a very long time and I was there for
about like 30 minutes at this window and
pushed beyond I think you know my idea
of the fictional part of the character
you know into another space and it was a
beautiful thing to discover and the pain
of that moment and to feel a lot of
Bostonians who are a crew who were so
deeply affected as the world was by the
event of the Marathon bombings feel that
energy and hand have us all feel
together and I learned two things I
learned that you know a crew like
everybody working is not only an
audience but we are all in it together
even if someone is behind here you guys
can't see them but we're all here
together and that's very powerful and
we're all kind of in it together and
then I also learned that you can't lose
your imagination that acting is like all
about imagination and there's a lot of
talk about like Oh commitment and you
know method acting and you know how far
do you go and blah blah blah everybody's
favorite conversation when you're
talking to an actor or not favorite
conversation but it is a conversation to
add a lot and I just believe so deeply
in your imagination
that's the fun it's like the play it's
what you need and I had lost it in that
moment and I and it threw me for a
number of days because I went so far and
I just realized that that's not acting
to me anymore
every movie you do you learn about the
process of of what you
you you know how far you can push it
what techniques you want to use and I've
used my career because I've been lucky
enough to work on a number of films I
was just formed my production company at
the time and we we produced that movie
alongside Mandeville produced as well my
company has become more about helping
other people tell their stories I'm not
in a lot of the movies that we produce
but I am occasionally and yes I you know
I've was brought up with storytellers
you know and that is that my real love
you know watching stories get made is
really exciting like I said before is
like watching an actor work is more
exciting than doing the acting myself
sometimes you know and I love performing
but it's just a magic of stories that I
want to keep trying to help if I have
the opportunity people know who I am and
that they know my name then I can lend
it to something to help it get made end
of watch what it did to my life in the
five months I did in preparation with
police officers around Los Angeles
County I'm in East LA and what I saw
just changed me forever to see the work
that they do to be with them watching
them do their work to be in sometimes
very dangerous situations and also
beautiful situations to see human
behavior at its most tried sometimes
changed everything in the way I see the
world so I look at that as a very very
particular moment in my life in my
career something I needed you know
alright this is my day job some sorry
Brahma Corey this is my day job some you
might know me as Brian the process of
filming was cool you know III fancy
myself a bit of a filmmaker and so we
were very much a part of the process of
shooting that movie we shot on camera
and so and I my character has a camera
that he's shooting with we didn't want
it to be cute you know and I actually
look at that as an extension you know
end of watch into a movie Nightcrawler
there's you know to me the movie of
Nightcrawler is the evolution of a
cameraman like that was my philosophy
the entire time the evolution of an
artist
Nightcrawler it's just fantastic writing
yeah it is it is tried-and-true
blueprint of anything that is great and
storytelling comes from the beginning
from great writing and that's not always
true doesn't always work that equation
but in the case of Nightcrawler it was
hands-down the exception of a few one of
the greatest screenplays I read a
character that already had been
developed profound ly by the by Dan
Gilroy before it even got to me and so I
had to do the finishing touches and
that's the way it should be very rarely
the way it is when I read it I just went
like oh my god he's given me thousands
of avenues so many choices but I had
this vision of this guy and he talked a
lot in the scripts in the way he talked
to so on and I was always trying to wrap
my head around it I just had this vision
of myself I just thought there could be
nothing physically imposing about this
guy it was all mind and from anything I
know about people who are like really
like blood up here more than anywhere
else in their body is that oftentimes
they're not thinking about like what
they're gonna eat next or if they can't
eat and or what they're gonna do next
they have one goal and one goal only and
that's where they're headed and I just
thought I got him gonna make myself into
that idea we spent you know 20 nights
shooting the movie 20 to shoot that
movies like nothing in movie time you
know and I just knew we'd have to go and
there were like three to four page
monologues you know that this guy had to
say so there was part of the reason why
the speed at which he speaks comes from
that comes from just going how do I as
an actor make sure this incredible
writing and the performance I'm gonna
give stays in the movie you have to say
it fast I also want to go to the next
room and meet your team and the station
manager and the director and the anchors
and start developing my own personal
relationships I'd like to start meeting
them this morning you'll take me around
you'll introduce me as the owner and
president of video production news and
remind them of some of my many other
stories people talk about him as like a
creepy sociopath and there's truth to
that and I think he is a prophetic he
was a prophetic sort of a symbol of
capitalism and leadership that we have
now come to become accustomed to but I
always looked at it like as this
beautiful artist learning how to use a
camera and the way what he was shooting
was obviously sort of perverse and sick
but at the same time he really looked at
himself as an artist and you can watch
him and that was for me that was big
thing so I'm most proud of in that movie
you could watch him the style of how he
shoots things change when he's moving
bodies you know it's just totally
illegal and disgusting in the movie you
know I don't know how much different
that is from a Damien Hirst painting or
David me a Hurst piece you know like
that's what he looked at it as that's
how my was my perspective of it which
while I was playing that character which
was fascinating and disturbing Brokeback
Mountain I think we had been cast for
our essences without really
understanding what our essences were and
that's outside of sexuality I mean we're
like two straight guys cast in these
roles but who we who we are who we were
and could see and I don't know if I
could so when the movie had the response
that it had I think all of us who had
been cast that includes every actor but
the main actors of Heath and me and Anne
Hathaway and Michelle Williams like I
think I don't think we recognized what
Aang had seen in us so we're sort of
wandering around blind at the profundity
and the echo that the movie made we
understood the power of the story but I
think playing a character in it we
didn't fully and I don't think we ever
had any idea would have the impact that
add here on dudes again next summer well
maybe not like I said me and I was
getting married November trying to get
something on the ranch I guess
you
my hope - my daddy's placing give my
hand your than where I'm gonna be back
the army don't get me anger this
incredible thing where he's very close
to you in the pre-production process
before you start filming and then in the
filming you become this sort of painting
he's watching and he doesn't want to
touch any of it to disturb it and it
becomes a bit cold actually I think he
has to focus his heart on the objective
well you you know do what you do in
front of him
I enjoy rehearsals and I believe that
writing should should hold up to the
rehearsal process and I think you
learned a lot in the rehearsal process
too you also just mostly break through
all I mean there's some moments or it's
nice to just meet somebody and go but I
find if you're gonna get to a place
where you really want to land with
someone you want to be present with them
it's very good
particularly in emotional things and
stuff like that you need to at least
spend enough time with them that all
that forgive me for but like all the
[ __ ] of like small talk goes away
and then you can get to it when I say
all we have is broke man I can't quit
you you know that those lines tell you
what we could have had a good life
together [ __ ] real good life how does
the place of our own but you in water
Danis so what we got now he's broke back
now everything's built on that that's
all we got boy [ __ ] off so I hope you
know that if you don't never know the
rest you count the damn few times that
we have been together in nearly 20 years
and you measure the short [ __ ] leash
you keep me on and then you ask me about
Mexico and you tell me you kill me for
needs something I don't hardly never get
you have no idea how bad it gets I'm not
you I can't make it on a couple of
high-altitude [ __ ] once or twice a year
you are too much for me yes sound horse
[ __ ] I wish I knew how to quit you we
had rehearsed it we had gone earlier
months earlier when it was still snowing
there and I remember it was about
covered in two or three feet of snow we
didn't even see what the ground looked
like at a time I had my dog who's now
passed away jumping through the snow I
remember and then the spring came and
everything melted and we shot the scene
and there was a like a palpable feeling
of that scene while we were doing it to
make a movie that's that even just works
is a miracle and when it resonates even
beyond that it's it's impossible and it
has nothing to do with you in the end
just being a Brokeback Mountain that's
the feeling I have I feel that deeply
about it it had nothing to do with me it
came to me I was honored to be a part of
it
and it is now everyone else's in a way
that I can't even fathom and that's why
I empathize with like any artist to any
director anybody does this cuz it's like
what an audience experience is and what
you experience are two totally different
things and oftentimes reconciling those
things is the weirdest part about it and
you never know what people are gonna
respond to you try your best at every
turn you put all your your time and your
heart and and your belief and the thing
that you're doing and I think that goes
for everybody and what everything they
do when you care and then you're just
constantly surprised by what people love
and what they don't
[Music]